[Music]
well hello everyone welcome to our
program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where you can send us your questions
and we'll do the research and do
everything possible to answer the
questions by referring to god's
infallible word
the bible
if you want to send us your questions
i'm going to give you the address where
you can send them
tv
at some tv dot org once again you can
see on the screen tv at some tv dot org
we'll be glad to answer your questions
we have a big pile of questions if we
don't answer yours uh soon
know that we will get to it eventually
anyway i have here with me
c.a murray
associate speaker of secrets unsealed
among many other things a very wise
counselor and very helpful here in our
ministry
and he's with us and i'm going to ask ca
if he would have a word of prayer and
then
we'll i'm going to throw a question at
you and i'll throw you a knuckleball
okay
let's pray shall we pray
gracious father we praise you and thank
you for the privilege that we have to
study your word
we thank thee that your word indeed is a
lamp unto our feet and a light unto our
path and that if we will walk in that
light it leads us to
the day when christ will come again so
father bless us today be with the words
that we say
the thoughts that we think may they be
infused with your holy spirit and may
those who seek answers who seek light
find those answers and find that light
on today's program we thank you father
for your blessings and your promise to
hear and answer the prayer of faith in
jesus name amen amen
well we have a series of questions that
have kind of a central theme they're
from
maura i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly peter is the last name
and
so i'll just throw out the first
question
and then we'll kind of go down the line
it might take us a whole program to
cover this particular
series of questions
this is the question based on
deuteronomy 32 39
and first samuel 2 verse 6
why do these verses say that god kills
or what is the meaning of this
so probably we should read deuteronomy
32 and verse 39 first of all all right i
have it from the new king james
now see that i even i am he
and there is no god besides me
i kill and i make alive i wound and i
heal
nor is there any who can deliver from my
hand
okay and first samuel 2 verse 6
basically says the same thing so we
don't need to read that verse so how do
we understand this concept
in this verse that god kills
i think one of the things that god is
doing here
before we begin to parse every single
word
god is asserting his sovereignty
over the affairs of men and this world
that everything that happens happens
under the watch care of god although he
may not
actually be responsible for every
individual act
that is to say uh we know that god is a
god of life he has a god of love that
satan is responsible for responsible for
death and for killing so god is saying
those things that happen in the lives of
men here on planet earth are under my
watch care and my sovereignty
and nothing happens that i don't allow
to happen although i may not be the
causal aspect of every individual
and in some cases god does the causal
act yes like in sodom and gomorrah the
flood that we studied this week you know
the lesson on
and you know the end of the world the
destruction of the world
but in many cases
god
simply allows satan to do something
because the individual has made their
own personal choice
so ultimately the person is responsible
for the destruction of the wicked not
god yes
we look at at at god
god's quote hardening of pharaoh's heart
um god really only has as you well know
one way of dealing with us and that
that's love uh ny tells us that love is
never inappropriate it's never out of
place but if love makes you angry
then what else can god do he cannot
change his methodology he cannot change
who he is he the lover that knoweth not
god for god is love so he's always going
to act uh towards the human family with
love but if if that if that hardens you
if that
turns you off
well then what else can he do but love
because that's who he is
so is the destruction of the wicked an
act of love on the part of god it is
indeed one thing that we know that god
is consistent and the wicked would not
be
at home at peace
in a world where everything is love and
everything is caring and everything is
other worldness you come from a world of
selfishness and self-centeredness and
replace in that atmosphere for all
eternity would be torture for you sure
and in love god does not force you into
that he he gives you the decision that
you've made you you want to be this way
you've rejected his overtures of love
well then that's what you can have and
basically the choice was made by the
wicked themselves precisely so it's not
an arbitrary act of god no it's not like
me going into a store and shooting
someone to to steal something you know
it's uh it's a actually a meeting out of
strict justice based on the decision
that the person made so the buck stops
with the person precisely when when when
the the command is given to you that is
just letting me just he that is unholy
uh let it be unholy he is simply
confirming what you've already a
decision you've already made i remember
years ago when i was in college
they had this committee that used to
send children home when they were just
encourageable you know give them time
again and a chance and another chance
and another chance then after all you
have to come before the committee and um
they'd say well you're kicking me out of
school they said no you you've shown by
your actions and you don't want to be
here right we have rules and and you
don't want to obey them so you said i
don't want to be here we're simply
granting you your wish very very good
illustration i like it
okay the next question is related to
this when it gives us a practical
example of what we just talked about
the bible also says in first samuel 16
23 if you want to look up that verse
that the evil spirit comes from the lord
can you plea please explain this to me
how
god sends evil spirits
so let's read first samuel 16 23 i think
it's talking about the spirit that
tormented saul king saul
so let's uh read that because it
illustrates uh what we just talked about
in the last few minutes okay uh
chapter 16 16 and verse 23 33
and so it was
whenever the spirit from god was upon
saul
excuse me
that david would take up a harp and play
it with
uh with his hand
then saul would become refreshed as well
and the distressing spirit would depart
from him
okay so there's a distressing spirit
sent by the lord to torment saul
and when david played his harp
the the torment uh at least for a season
uh departed so how do does god send evil
spirits uh to torment people
uh no god god god neither torments nor
attempts anywhere that's anyone you know
i i was thinking about about this in
just very human terms when when the lord
is trying to
uh
saul had
divorced himself from god
he had separated himself from god ellen
white says this about saul
that in his life he had no real
self-control he had never really been
converted and had never known the
converting soothing power of the holy
spirit he was he was elected
he was selected
mostly because he was taller and better
looking than everybody else he was the
best looking guy in the kingdom and he
was taller than everybody so
but inside all of that patina he had no
heart
and um
um
the spirit of god left him and of course
we live in a a universe where there's no
vacuum and once the spirit of god goes
then you're left to the devices of of
satan so if we can't lay this at the
feet of god uh this is again a series of
decisions saul had made for for himself
so basically what god is doing
is because saul chose to
totally reject god
that god then allowed satan
he withdrew drew his protection based on
the decision of saul of saul and he
allowed satan
to go
and to torment saul yes here's one of
the things that we find very interesting
pastor
if you if if we were to look at the
rap sheet
of david and saul
david's is much longer
and and and really some heinous things
he did
um saul is his rap sheet is much shorter
but
the glaring difference between the two
people is when david was was
caught and called on
uh for his sins
david said rebuke me in other words
spank me but count to ten you know calm
down but then spend me but he didn't try
to get out from under
the um the punishment of god
he knew that god was just and i'll take
my punishment whereas saul always had an
excuse always had some reason always had
some rationale and and and the repentant
attitude you see you find thought the
bible counts a lot with god
you know uh you made a mistake well god
is not willing to wash you out for one
mistake but your attitude really
determines
how you're going to respond to that
punishment and saul just just was not
one to take punishment he always had
some reason always had some rationale so
the the the chain was much shorter on
saul than david although david's sins
were much longer david repented uh and
died in the faith and he repented of the
sin
not repented of the consequences
precisely uh you know
saul you know he says i offered the
sacrifice because the the soldiers were
deserting
and he says you know i saved all these
animals even though you told us to
destroy all the animals because i felt
that they could be used in the
sacrificial system
so the greatest evidence of a lack of
repentance is passing the buck or
blaming somebody else yes yes and making
excuses yes you refer to it a a a text
uh another text rather a a statement by
ellen white that i've gone through many
many times where she says the greatest
praise of god is obedience you know it's
not just saying praise god praise god
praise god praise god it's obeying god
and following his dictates and that is
something that saul just simply
would not do
now as a follow-up on this something
related
is the question about the census of
israel
you know there's a text in second samuel
24 and verse 1
that says
that
god told
david to count israel
and then there's another text that says
that satan stood up against israel and
provoked david to number israel so in
one text that by the way is first
chronicles chapter 21 and verse one so
the question is who is enticing david to
count israel to do a census of israel is
it god or is it satan
in the light of what we've been
discussing yes again
this this really dovetails uh back to
what we're saying david's list of sins
is really quite extensive uh he made a
lot of
blunders and a lot of mistakes
he reigned i think around 33 years or so
ball was much shorter
and in 33 years of of being a king you
can you can make some mistakes and he
did
uh this
um
numbering of israel was was a lack of
faith it it really really really was but
again we look at at the at the response
um you referred to second samuel chapter
uh second samuel 24 verse 1 24 1. uh in
first chronicles 21 verse 1 says the
seems to say the opposite
again
the the author of lies and deceit
and and rebellion against god is
is satan
uh we know from the from the new
testament that a house divided against
cannot stand so god is not going to do
one thing in one place and another
another but god will allow
uh
certain choices to be made
once we move in that direction and of
course satan is the actual doer but it
is done under
the i mean god is aware of everything
that happens and he allows certain
things to happen uh and we many times
have to pay the consequences for our
hard-headed decision
the the punishment was severe
in this case so the big question would
be this
would god
personally entice david to do a census
of israel
so that he could meet out this severe
and terrible punishment
obviously not yeah what's happening here
is that david decides that he's going to
do a census of israel contrary to god's
will
and god as a result
actually allows he allows satan
to
influence david on the basis of david's
decision due to the census of israel and
then
david and israel suffer the consequences
so once again it's not god who's doing
it yes it's god who's permitting this
based on the decision that david made to
do a census of israel contrary to god's
will correct one of the things that that
when you approach the bible
you have to approach with with a certain
amount of groundwork and understanding
one of the things that god do with all
things well two is the fact that god
always deals with love and he is
consistent
the the greatest gift and i was talking
with someone just the other night we
were talking about this same issue
the greatest gift that god gave humanity
aside from the death of christ which
makes all things possible
is the power to choose
you can always choose and before
punishment or reward for that matter is
passed out a choice is made adam and eve
made a choice kane and abel made a
choice
choices are made and those choices lead
to certain irrevocable ends if you make
that choice this is going to happen if
you make this choice that is going to
happen obey and live
disobey and die always there is a choice
and that's that's the greatest gift the
death of christ makes available to us
that we can have the power to choose and
god will say all right i want you to
choose this choose life and live
but if you want that well then you can
you can you can have that
you know prime example of this might be
second thessalonians chapter two
ii thessalonians chapter two is talking
about the great apostasy that was going
to take place in the christian church
after jesus ascended to heaven
and you know if we read
chapter 2 and verses 9 through 11
it speaks about the coming of the
lawless one
in these words the coming of the lawless
one
is according to the working of satan
with all power signs and line wonders so
so the lawless one acts uh as an
emissary of satan
and then it says in verse 10
and with all unrighteous deception among
those who perish
now why do they perish
because they did not receive the love of
the truth that they might be saved so
this is their personal choice right they
did not receive the love of the truth
and uh therefore uh they they give in to
the power of the antichrist or of this
uh this being that is being spoken of
here
and then in verse 11 it says and for
this reason because they didn't receive
the love of the truth which is their own
personal choice yes because
of this reason god will send them strong
delusion that they should believe the
lie that they may be condemned who did
not believe the truth but had pleasure
and unrighteousness so some people have
problems with where it says here that
god sends them a strong delusion but
it's really god allowing satan to send a
strong delusion upon them
because their choice has been to reject
the truth well said and you have to look
at the sequence because we see this
strong delusion idea repeated in the
book of romans but again the sequence
says after they have
shown their love of unrighteousness then
the strong delusion comes so they've
sort of made this left turn
and then god just confirms them in that
left turn oh you want to go this way
well then here's more evidence to to
cement you in that but the original
decision was not god's it was man's at
the behest of satan and he allowed satan
to delude them yes because they chose
delusion
okay one further example because this is
a really really important question that
always comes up because you know the
devil wants us to think that god is the
one who's deluding people that god is
leading people a lie and everything when
really it's a person's choice god
withdraws his hand yes and he allows
satan to come in and do his work the
book of job is very interesting let's go
there for just a few moments
job chapter 1
here satan is complaining to god because
god has put a hedge around job
in other words god has not allowed satan
to do anything to job
that's job chapter 1
and verse 10 when you have it i'll have
you read that
all right job 1 and verse 10 reading
from the
new king james
have you not made a hedge around him
around his household and around all
that he has on every side you have
blessed the work of his hands and his
possessions have increased in the land
and then verse 11
but now stretch out your hand and touch
all that he has and he will surely curse
you to your face
so so satan is saying to god he's
complaining saying
of course job serves you you put a hedge
around him you put a fence around him
you don't allow me to have access to him
but if you allow this is an important
point if you allowed me if god allowed
him yes
to
uh touch job to take to remove the hedge
satan says he will curse you to your
face
so so then
satan goes out
and he does it now let's notice that
satan says here to god stretch out your
hand he's saying to god stretch out your
hand and touch all that he has and he
will surely curse you to his face
is it really god then in the next part
of the story that stretch that stretches
out his hand and touches everything that
job has
no who is it
well
yeah let's read job chapter 1 and verse
12.
and the lord said to satan behold all
that he has is in your power so god is
allowing it
only do not lay a hand on his person so
satan went out from the presence of the
lord and so satan now takes everything
away from job yes
so here we have a clear illustration
of how this works
you know god removes the hedge
satan
does this affliction to job it's not god
doing it directly it's god allowing
satan to do it and of course the whole
book of job tells us that's a there's a
purpose behind that yes this is a
beautiful illustration pastor because it
kind of pulls the curtain back and shows
you that the behind-the-scenes working
of principalities and powers uh god is
there god is in control satan can go no
further but the actual damage if we can
use that term is being done by satan
himself and god is going to show god god
is really trying to contradict satan's
argument
that the followers of god
follow him for the loaves and the fishes
yes they're mercenaries
because god because god gives them god
protects them you know and god make
prospers them yes then it you know of
course they're going to serve you satan
says but if if you certainly allowed me
to take away everything from them
they would immediately curse you to your
face and of course job passed the test
yes god looked good and satan looked
pretty bad
before the entire universe because the
heavenly council was watching this
uh you know let's go to job
42 verse 11.
this puts it in perspective jo 42 11.
now who is it that caused all of job's
problems it was satan clearly chapters 1
and 2 tell us that satan was the one who
took everything from him satan gave him
the boils afflicted him etc but notice
what job 40 42 and verse 11 has to say
it says then all his brothers
and all his sisters and those who had
been his acquaintances before
came to him and ate food with him in his
house and they consoled him and
comforted him for all the adversity that
the lord had brought upon him
but the lord hadn't brought it upon him
chapter 1 says that satan brought it
upon him so once again it's the
principle
that god allows
sometimes satan to do certain things i
call it his permissive will god has a
causative will virtue and god has a
permissive will
and in this story he does it to make a
point yes that job serves him because he
loves him in other cases
it's simply an individual has said no to
god
once and for all that's been the choice
and god simply removes his protection
and allows satan free reign to that
person i think two things stand out one
god is sovereign but also god is not
arbitrary god will will will work with
you god will will labor with you but
ultimately he will let you have what you
wish and of course judgment is that way
um we are told in the spirit of prophecy
that one good deed and a
life of bad will not get you in one bad
deed and it will not keep you out but
god is looking at the pattern he's
looking at the way you're going he's
looking at your mindset he's looking at
your repentance for your sins he's
looking he's looking at how you respond
to punishment to blessings to cursings
all of that is weighed in how god deals
with each one of us and we know that uh
every act
whether it seems good or bad is an act
of love and is for our own best good
you know there's the principle
whatsoever a man soweth
that shall he also reap revelation so so
you sow certain choices yes and you're
going to reap certain results
but the results are not god's problem
they're not caused by god they're not
they're caused by our wrong choices
and repentance means saying to the lord
lord i blew it
there's no excuses
nobody else did it
the buck stops here yes please forgive
me for what i did
not for the consequences please please
don't you know cut off the consequences
so the consequences don't come
because god will allow the consequences
to come because whatever we sow is also
what we reap yeah yeah the first part of
that text is so important don't be
deceived don't play games with your own
head god is not mocked you can't cheat
him you cannot outfox him you cannot
i'll thank him you cannot hide from him
you cannot run from him he knows and you
won't get away unscathed unless you
accept the blood of christ well i think
the bottom line here
is that we need to make the right
choices yes we need to make informed
choices we need to
to follow what god says in his holy word
and then
the consequences will be positive even
though they might appear negative god
isn't going to allah is going to allow
his people to go through the final time
of trouble yes it's going to be intense
suffering
god's people will suffer hunger they're
not going to die of hunger they'll
suffer thirst they'll be persecuted some
of them will be thrown into prison
they'll lose their liberty
and so you know where is god at that
point well god is once again allowing
this to happen to make a point yes that
god has an entire generation at the end
of time that serves him because they
love him and not all of self-interest i
think once we settle in our mind first
john 4 8 he that loveth not knoweth not
god for god is love that that is the
overriding theme of how god deals with
us he loves you he loves me so whatever
we go to and go through
it is being done by a god of love
and he's always on your side he's not
trying to keep you out he's trying to
get you in and if you but choose him and
choose him this day he's going to save
you amen amen praise the lord well we
have just a minute left and i want to
take this
opportunity to encourage all of those
who are watching this program to check
out our summit
secrets unsealed summit the last weekend
of october it's a phenomenal experience
up near yosemite national park
fantastic food both spiritual and
literal fantastic fellowship
time to be in the midst of nature
enjoying the beauty of god's creation
yeah
you know you you won't be sorry that you
decided to come to our summit this year
uh you we haven't been able to have the
summit for a couple of years we've had
just a virtual summit
but this year
lord willing we're going to be able to
do it in person and i would love to see
many of you who listen to this program
and watch this program to be there at
our summit
so
please check it out go to our website
secretsoundseal.org and you'll be able
to find the information there well when
you're having a good time
time flies by
uh i trust that uh the answer to these
questions has been satisfactory
the answers have come from god's word
god bless you and keep you in his care
and we hope to see you next time on this
program i'd like to know
[Music]
you